from zoomers to those born in the first
millennium
a.d the avengers come in a wide range of
ages
and while these heroes are certainly
proof that age is just a number
that doesn't mean we're not curious
about it so how old was each avenger
during
end game there are many complicated
answers when it comes to figuring out
the ages of
everyone in avengers end game so let's
start simple
peter parker was among the victims of
thanos snap
we know peter was born in 2001 which
would have made him 17
both when he was snapped and when he
returned an end game
he didn't age despite time around him
moving as normal
if peter hadn't been snapped away he
would be 22
in 2023 we know that natasha romanov aka
black widow was born in 1984 which would
have made her 39 when she appeared in
end game
that said black widow died when she and
clint barton
aka hawkeye traveled back to 2014 to
carry out the time heist on vermeer and
secure the soul stone
one might think that means she died at
the age of 30 but it's important to
remember that it's the 2023 version of
black widow
who traveled back in time and sacrificed
herself she still made it to 39 years of
age
despite dying in 2014 on the timeline
wanda maximoff is also an 80s baby she
was 29 when she got snapped in
avengers infinity war the current
captain america
sam wilson was born in 1978 making him
39 years old at the time of the snap
that means when we see him again in the
falcon and the winter soldier
he's chronologically 45. getting into
some of the older guard we have
tony stark who was born in 1970 and
bruce banner who was born in 1969
that would make their end game ages 53
and 54 years old respectively
thanks to his character's personnel
badge and iron man
we know that james rhodes is also a
member of the 50 plus club
he was born in 1968 making him 55 years
old and end game
as for the much older guard we have
steve rogers
captain america was born in 1918 making
him 105 years old during the events of
endgame
however he was frozen in 1945 at the age
of 27
and started aging again when he was
thawed in 2012.
i went in the ice in 45 right after i
met the love of my life
i woke up 70 years later at the time of
end game
that would make him physically 38 years
old cap himself
seems to be conflicted about how to view
his actual age
in captain america the winter soldier he
tells natasha quote
i'm 95. i'm not dead of course steve
appears as an elderly man in the final
moments of endgame
so his physical age becomes more like 90
plus by the end of the movie
maybe uh try some of that life
tony was telling me to get
steve's longtime buddy bucky barnes aka
the winter soldier has had an even more
complicated aging trajectory considering
he was thought out more often between
the early 20th century and present day
he also got snapped by thanos in
infinity war
so while chronologically his 1917 birth
year would make him 106
in 2023 it's harder to say how
physically
old that would leave bucky given he can
fight with the best of them
and that he's battling more bad guys in
disney plus as the falcon and the winter
soldier
bucky's physical age can't be much older
than steve's pre-old man cap
transformation
even though he may not always act it the
granddaddy of them all
is thor who stated in avengers infinity
war that he was roughly 1500 years old
that would make him roughly 1505 during
the events of endgame
for all the ages we do know there are
some that remain
inconclusive characters like hawkeye
t'challa
and doctor strange haven't been given
canonical birthdays in the mcu
at least not yet for heroes such as
hawkeye we can assume he's meant to be
around the same age as the actor who
plays him as of july 2021
jeremy renner is 50 years old but the
end game ages of others
like dr strange who's fond of slipping
into other dimensions
and ant-man who spent a few earth years
in the timeless quantum realm
are a bit harder to figure out benedict
cumberbatch turns 44 in 2021
and paul rudd is shockingly enough 52
but as 37 year old chris hemsworth can
tell you just because the mcu character
you play
looks like they could be the same age as
you doesn't mean they are
on that note while we don't know the
exact date of carol danvers birth
we do know that the events resulting in
her gaining her powers happened in 1989.
presuming she's meant to be in her
mid-20s during the events of captain
marvel
that would put her birth date sometime
in the 1960s
however considering the powers she
received stop her from aging
and the fact that she spent a number of
years hopping around space
it's hard to pinpoint exactly how old
captain marvel is by endgame
just going chronologically she would be
in her 60s
although her appearance is still that of
someone in their 20s or 30s
there's also the case of some of the
semi-human
and non-human avengers the age of nebula
is a total mystery
she belongs to the lupamoid species of
aliens but it seems that her adoptive
father
thanos lost her paperwork as we don't
even know how old nebula is meant to be
in luffa-mordian years
and last but certainly not least is
rocket raccoon
mcu fans know that despite his name and
general appearance rocket is not
in fact an actual raccoon but rather a
genetically
engineered half-worlder the only bit of
information we have to go on regarding
rocket's age is pretty morbid
his own admission and guardians of the
galaxy in which he says
i don't get that long a lifespan anyway
check out one of our newest videos right
here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite marvel movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]